lisa jackson bonjour ici monsieur
heureux aujourd'hui on va parler d'un
smartphone dont j'ai déjà parlé
plusieurs fois giuseppe présentation
globale de ce smartphone en cédant s'est
posé la question est-ce que ça
smartphones haut de gamme ou moyenne
gamme et aujourd'hui on va l'ouvrir et
là il est beau il est dans sa boîte dans
son carton de bien protéger tout doux on
va l'ouvrir on va regarder s'il est bien
pour faire un oeil boxing est dans une
très très très prochaine vidéo on va
faire un test complet et on va regarder
si ce smartphone est super cool oui ou
non et ce smartphone c'est le one piece
et on y va
le monde + 6 je vous en ai déjà beaucoup
parler je vous ai fait des vidéos de
rumeurs avant pour essayer petit peu de
prendre la tendance est de voir à quoi
allait ressembler ce one + 6 est-ce
qu'il allait être intéressant séduisant
oui ou non ensuite lorsqu'il a été
annoncé par une plus je vous ai fait une
vidéo pour vous donner les
caractéristiques techniques pour voir se
produit comment ils situer par rapport
au reste du marché
et dans cette vidéo je vous en ai dit
effectivement que le one piece
je crois que c'était un produit
intéressant dans moyen de gamme on a
sauté à la gorge et j'arrive
parfaitement le comprendre on a dit non
monsieur re ce n'est pas un téléphone
moyen de gamme
le one plus si c'est un téléphone très
oubliable et justement vous ai fait une
vidéo pour poser la question est ce que
le one piece d'un smartphone moyen de
gamme ou haut de gamme pour faire cette
vidéo j'ai regardé les caractéristiques
techniques voir ce qu'ils proposent et
par rapport à des smartphones mais
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance de l'avoir en
main de l'avoir ici dans le carton on va
l'ouvrir ensemble on va regarder s'il
est bien et comme je vous disais si
quelques jours qu'est ce que quelques
petits jours on va faire un test complet
comme ça au moins vous saurez si ce
smartphone est intéressant oui ou non
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse je vous ai
mis des liens dans la description vous
avez un peu tous les tarifs c'est un
smartphone qui est disponible chez
amazon qu'on peut trouver chez rbs
et vous pouvez aussi avoir chez bouygues
telecom si vous êtes client chez eux et
aussi sur le site domaine plus mon papa
attendre plus longtemps on nous l'a dit
voici ce joli carton on va l'ouvrir sans
plus attendre voici le souveraine +6 là
on est blanc semblant se rend pas trop
compte
j'adore cette couleur je trouve vraiment
très très belle à l'intérieur j'ai en
plus de ça des écouteurs tout sympa mais
bon aujourd'hui c'est pas le sujet en
tout cas ils sont là ils ont le mérite
d'exister ça c'est une très très très
très bonne chose
voici la boîte du one + 6 je trouve
qu'ils ont vraiment extrêmement bien
réussi leur packaging vous avez si une
sur briance avec le 6 le logo ici ou en
plus il est décrit ici ou en plus six au
cas où vous ne seriez pas quel téléphone
vous avez acheté ce speed you need et
ode aux différentes informations ici
c'est le modèle 64 giga le mirror blacks
on va l'ouvrir sans plus attendre
voilà j'adore je trouve que c'est
vraiment très très bien réussie vous
ouvrez vous tombez directement sur le
produit
il est pas simple à récupérer on va
éviter de le jeter partout il est un
petit peu bien accrochés au moins comme
ça risque pas de se barrer une fois que
vous avez enlevé tous les autocollants
qui se trouvait au dos vous vous
retrouvez avec un smartphone hyper sobre
est vrai
entré très très joli la finition de
soignies +6 extrêmement bien réussi vous
avez de votre double module photo votre
flash votre 14 d'empreintes digitales
leleu roanne puis 6 et emballe info
designed by one plus sur la face avant
on va très bien cette petite encoche on
aperçoit bien l'écran qui est quasiment
un bord à bord son côté ici vous avez
votre slide votre bouton marche arrêt de
l'autre côté les boutons volume votre
haut parleur mono la prise usb type c
est ici votre port jack vous avez du
gorilla glass 5 à l'avant mais également
à l'arrière un dos en verre par contre
pas de recharge à induction là dessus
pour recharger pour le das charge la
charge rapide
si vous utilisez pas à le charger bastia
que vous utilisez un chargeur classique
il se rechargera un rythme assez
classique il vous aurait pas cette
recharge rapide vole un peu pour ce
smartphone on va maintenant regarder un
petit peu ce qu'il ya dans la boîte voir
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant là dedans
alors je vous dis une fois de plus moi
j'adore chaussée très très très bien
design et les couleurs sont vraiment
bien choisi il faut savoir que comme je
vous le disais la recharge rapide se
situe ici et non pas dans le smartphone
donc il faut bien garder ça pour le
recharger pour pouvoir profiter d'une
recharge rapide en une demi-heure vous
aller recharger à plus de 60% ici de la
même manière votre câble qui est là qui
enroulait j'adore vraiment je trouve que
d'un point de vue teinte d'un point de
vue couleurs d'un point de vue
esthétique
il ya vraiment une très très très belle
réussite des accessoires du produit
c'est vraiment super joli j'adore la
couleur de ce câble mais l'intérieur
vous retrouvez cette couleur c'est top
ici on va trouver les notices
d'utilisation qui soit pas ici vient par
la voilà vous avez donc ici une coque de
protection le guide de démarrage rapide
pour savoir comment démarrer ce
smartphone vous avez ici votre double
nano sim le bouton de volume comme je
vous le disais l'écouteur le connecteur
usb type c'est le capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui au dos de l'appareil
bouton marche arrêt et derrière slider
jusque là j'ai tout bon safety in
formation'' d'ide et quelques petits
autocollants ou est de plus en plus pour
votre plus on arrêtait les jeunes ont un
peu bidon vous avez coques de
protections plastiques c'est un effet un
peu cheap of one plus on propose
directement sur son site vous pouvez les
acheter
celle là est pas terrible a le mérite
d'exister et d'être dedans donc ça c'est
vraiment un très très bon point d'autres
grandes marques pourraient s'inspirer
mais voilà là je le smartphone en mirror
blacks
il est comme ça extrême
jolie pour ça vraiment dommage d'aller
mettre ça à l'intérieur alors évidemment
ça vous protège vraiment votre
smartphone mais par contre voilà je
trouve pas ça très très très joli ça
vous rajoute un espèce de petit bord sur
le côté c'est un smartphone qui est très
bien réussi qui est très beau c'est
toujours très très très dommage d'aller
mettre des coques de protection surtout
quand elles sont pas terribles donc si
vous voulez en métro et je vous
recommande pour protéger allez on assume
directement sur le site du wan plus et
vous verrez c'est beaucoup plus joli jeu
vous met quelques liens aussi dans la
description c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
voilà pour le home boxing de ce voile +6
je vous invite à rester connectés parce
que d'ici quelques jours je vous publier
le test complet vous dire comment je me
trouvais ce qu'il est bien pas bien
intéressant oui non à qui il s'adresse
est-ce qu'il faut l'acheter à quel prix
puisque pour trouver les meilleurs prix
les meilleures voies pour acheter soren
+6 donc restez connectés mark et moi
maintenant toutes vos questions
suggestions avis directement en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous l'avez déjà
acheté est ce que vous avez un one + 5
vous avez au moins plus 5 t est ce que
vous avez un web plus trois cousins et
one + 3 t es ce que vous avez un one
plus one est ce que vous avez déjà eu
des produits de plus qu'est ce que vous
en pensez ce qui sont intéressants pour
vous est-ce qu'ils sont séduisants
mark et moi tout ça directement en bas
en commentaires qu'on puisse en discuter
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
merci d'être toujours plus nombreux
toujours plus nombreuses sur la chaîne
nous vous êtes un honorable
laissez-moi des jolies tous abonnés vous
il ya très bientôt tél 15
[Musique]